bad news justice league your movie tanks
now i have no choice but to call the one
superhero who's still capable of saving
the dc
universe what are you talking about the
only superhero who isn't here is yes
oh no go for aquaman ah
man knew i should have sprung for that
[Music]
case
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that has the ability to
communicate with fish
good fish very good fish loyal theorists
back in 2018
millions of people flooded the theaters
and swam through
packed lobbies to watch a really cool
guy named arthur curry become
well an even cooler guy responsible for
saving both land and sea
atlantis has always had a king now i
need something more
a hero a king fights only for his nation
you fight for everyone the james wan
directed aquaman was a global smash hit
that pulled in 1.1 billion dollars
worldwide
while riding the dc extended universe
ship after justice league sunk at the
box office
so how did james wan manage to pull it
off by giving dc fans a downright
bonkers movie where it feels like the
producers just said yes to every single
idea
that juan had indiana jones side plot
yes
an annabelle the evil doll cameo yes
explosions to end
every single scene yes ripping through
the ocean floor on a giant leviathan to
decimate a shark
army with lasers on their head shell yes
i have one simple request and that is to
have
sharks with freaking laser beams
attached to their heads never mind pesky
details like you know
consistency of aquaman's powers as long
as you've got yourself an
octopus playing drums i am all about it
now throughout the film arthur the half
human son of the queen of atlantis is
reminded many times
probably too many times in fact that he
is the one true heir to the atlantean
throne and will one day unite the worlds
of
land and sea the throne is yours by
birthright
the only way to stop this war and save
both worlds
is for you to take your rightful place
as king but are you
really sure about that one mira because
by the end of the movie arthur the man
who will bridge the gap between land and
sea
doesn't deliver on any of that stuff oh
sure he does take the rightful throne i
give you
king arthur of atlantis into
but arthur is nobody's hero in this
movie if you actually look at his
actions throughout the film arthur
devastates
both land and sea with wanton abandon
or should i say wanton abandon i hate
myself i am so sorry he's originally
brought into the fight under this
premise your half-brother king orm is
about to declare war upon the surface
world
billions will die but in rising to the
throne arthur
creates just as if not more destruction
than his brother
theorists this is not your parents
aquaman and no i'm not just talking
about the fact that he got like
outrageously sexy as you're about to see
our historically pro-fish protagonists
send scores of endangered sea creatures
to their deaths and not only is the dude
peta's worst nightmare he doesn't really
give a flying fish about the lives of
the land dwellers either i mean you
probably already suspected that aquaman
kinda sucked but did you think the
reason would be for his super human lack
of empathy
hold your breath and plug your nose dear
theorists cause today we're throwing
some cold water on jason mamoa's
cold-hearted aquaman ah dang it the
water just made him even sexier didn't
it so the scene in aquaman that really
got my theorist juices flowing is this
climactic battle
at the brine a lava-heavy area of the
ocean populated by large crabs who
seemingly just want to be left alone so
they can build their lava catapults
honestly
relatable throughout the movie we've
seen step by step the evil orm
slowly taking over the various
underwater kingdoms in his quest to
become the ocean
master the last kingdom standing in his
way is the brine
the stakes are high if he's able to win
this battle he'll command the greatest
army on the planet and in so doing we'll
be able to wipe out
every land dweller with ease prepare
your armies
your highness we move against the brian
kingdom at once
admittedly it's a bit weird that orm
needs so many armies to help him out
considering earlier in the film he's
able to summon waves that cause
trillions of dollars of damage to the
eastern seaboard
and straight up washes warships onto the
shore but hey let's not get bogged down
in the plots
james juan certainly didn't this was
orm's doing the worst is yet to come
anyway just as oram's about to claim
victory by killing the brine king a
gigantic
eruption comes from the ocean floor as
the karen thin
uh sorry the karethan an ancient beast
measuring
3.2 kilometers that's two miles for us
imperial system land dwellers bursts up
and
under the control of aquaman himself
promptly destroys the ever-living
daylight out of
everything in sight soldiers from both
armies
sea creatures carrying soldiers on their
backs small ships medium ships
large ships if it exists aquaman is here
to destroy it
no questions asked and see this is where
aquaman's behavior starts to get a
little squeaky i mean
the first major round of casualties are
the crab
people of the brine remember these were
the last hold outs against king orm
you will never have my allegiance
so be it and yet this primarily
ground-based army
are the first casualties of aquaman as
the karethan rips through the ocean
floor to launch an attack in this one
dramatic entrance aquaman destroys
thousands of their troops and a huge
chunk of the brine homeland i mean that
just kinda sucks
now that alone wouldn't be all that big
of a deal sure aquaman doesn't properly
contain his new pet a beast that would
make godzilla pee in his pants but you
see
that's not all aquaman possesses the
trident of atlan
a staff that gives him the ability to
communicate to all sea life well kind of
unlike your old school aquaman from 1941
who could just talk to fish
arthur seems to be taking a page out of
2011's aquaman where his ability is to
reach into the midbrains of sea
creatures and control them
telepathically
sometimes against their will and if you
need proof of this look no further than
the animation
he takes hold of the trident and is
immediately connected to everyone's
neurological system
so what does aquaman king of atlantis
hero of the sea do with his newfound
power he summons
thousands of unarmed whales dolphins
fish and manta rays to join the fight
sure it's an impressive visual but he's
sending
unarmored animals charging headfirst
into an army of
deadly laser-shooting armored foes and
what's more
a ton of these animals who again are
actively being compelled to fight via
aquaman's 100 consent free brain hack
trick
are on the endangered species list
here's a quick rundown of the ones i was
able to pick out amid the visual chaos
great hammerhead shark endangered
narwhal
near threatened blue whales endangered
various dolphin species some of which
are endangered
killer whales endangered fin whales
endangered
great white sharks vulnerable i know
that there's a lot of chaos on screen
but try watching it frame by frame and
you suddenly see that there's even
sharks attacking other sharks why is
aquaman allowing this
it seems like he never considered his
actions and the end result is just the
death of endangered animals
and animal on animal violence all win
it's worth noting you could have just
sent all the animals away and won the
battle using the caravan
who very clearly was just unaffected by
any and all attempts to attack it to rub
salt water into the atlantean's wounds
aquaman even summons
thousands of trench monsters who
literally tear apart
anyone and anything in their path
notably warriors who were only forced
into the battle after orm killed their
leader
and does aquaman care no because clearly
he doesn't care about the lives of
innocent people and animals in the
slightest and if you think i'm
exaggerating during the melee instead of
stopping the carnage he opts to enjoy a
nice
long kiss with meera in a scene that
outright starts with her saying
this there are too many casualties we
have to stop fighting now we need to
stop the fighting now
or at least after a 25 second make out
sesh and an erect trident gag
and to cap it all off he hops on a sea
dragon and rides it directly into the
mouth of orm's tylosaur
once again makes for a very cool visual
but he takes a beautiful sea creature
innocent and sacrifices it for no reason
like was he hoping that the tylosaur
would choke on the sea dragon you know
it's not a good look when orm a guy who
wants to kill
every land dweller cares enough about
his sea creature army to deck him out
with armor while our hero sends
armorless endangered whales to collide
with enemy ships all throughout this
battle arthur shows absolutely
zero concern for the people and
creatures of the sea
he tears through the brine his allies in
the battle he shows no mercy to the
warriors forced to march alongside orm
and he hacks into the midbrains of
endangered sea creatures to force him to
fight on his behalf against a vicious
armored battalion you can even see the
sharks struggling to resist against his
control
so okay that pretty much covers
aquaman's complete and utter disdain for
sea life
but that's nothing compared to his
disdain for the land dwellers let's go
back to that moment that aquaman bursts
up through the ocean floor riding the
caravan
now i understand that he needed to rush
into battle and while his entrance
certainly makes waves it uh well it it
makes
waves literal literal waves forget the
fact that aquaman's bursting up out of
the seafloor stun
instantly kills countless crab soldiers
defending the brine
look at how much of the seafloor is
getting displaced now the caravan
is huge around two miles long or about
3.2 kilometers
and ripping a massive two-mile hole
through the crust of the ocean floor is
gonna cause some massive complications
i mean think about it the caravan who
resides in earth's core which is
presumably located in earth's actual
core
just burrowed up through approximately 2
900 kilometers of earth that's about
1800 miles for all you imperialists out
there
and the water that was just sitting
calmly in the ocean
suddenly is massively shifting to fill
that hole this is gonna result in some
huge redistribution of sediment
displacing the water column in an
unbelievable fashion plus it's a
disruption to the brine which is already
a tectonically active region
that my friends is a recipe for a
tsunami
a tsunami that's likely gonna cost
thousands of innocent land dwellers
their lives now normally tsunamis giant
destructive water waves
originate from displacement in oceans
caused by earthquakes massive landslides
or explosions so i can't say with a
hundred percent certainty what would
happen when a gigantic two mile long
kaiju explodes through the ocean floor
after traveling from a hidden world but
watch just how much of the seafloor is
displaced when the keratin
explodes from the earth and this isn't
just a small shifting of tectonic plates
this is
multiple miles of ocean floor exploding
for comparison consider the tohoku
earthquake from 2011.
back in 2011 japan underwent a horrific
natural disaster when a massive
underground earthquake rocked the ocean
this earthquake measured in
at 9.0 on the richter scale making it
the fourth
most powerful earthquake in the world
since modern record keeping began
but this underwater earthquake while
powerful wasn't the major threat it was
the ensuing tsunami that it created
the shifting of tectonic plates resulted
in a massive amount of water
displacement
triggering powerful tsunami waves that
reached heights of about 40.5 meters or
133 feet
killing an estimated 16 000 people as
water surged into the cities
for perspective this natural disaster
was so big
it moved the main island of japan 2.4
meters
east that's right the full country moved
eight
feet over because of this and that's not
all it
shifted the entire planet on its axis
researchers estimate that the planet
moved between 10 centimeters and 25
centimeters which also affected its
rotational speed by
1.8 microseconds per day and all of this
came from a tectonic shift that was
about 7 miles long
or 11 kilometers certainly a bit longer
than the korethan but
then again the ground shifted vertically
by about three feet
or one meter because of the earthquake
with the korethan there were suddenly
massive holes blown in the crust of the
earth so
definitely a more girthy hole if not
quite as long the long and short of this
is that aquaman's dramatic arrival on
the back of the karethan would cause
unfathomable amounts of water to collide
and the displacement would undoubtedly
send waves careening towards land on par
with undersea earthquakes clocking in
between seven and a half and nine and a
half on the richter scale
the actual destruction this would cause
would depend on where the brine is
located in the sea which because of this
movie's insane geographic jumps is
nearly impossible to track that said my
best guess would be somewhere in the
pacific ocean near japan
why well 75 of the earth's volcanoes are
located in the pacific's ring of fire
and the massive japanese spider crab
which is the largest crab on earth and
reminiscent of the brine's crab
people live in the temperate waters near
japan but anyway
regardless aquaman sucks as the king of
the sea but
don't let that obscure the fact that he
also sucks as hero of the land
sure he quote unquote saved the world
from king arm but in the process he sent
destructive tsunamis out to the shores
of the land
and forced endangered animals to throw
away their lives while he got to first
base with
a girl countless people and animals died
needlessly as a result of aquaman's
actions and this so-called hero and
uniter
couldn't care less he's gonna begin his
reign with a whole lot of people united
all right
united in their hatred against him trust
me
i am no kin i agree i agree too
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and
finn creatures of the ocean summon your
power swarm that subscribe button we may
not become the ocean master but we will
become
the youtube master we're so close to
that 10 million mark
[Music]
you